[Applause]
[Music]
I'm Jennifer Baron of the garment
district and we are in Pittsburgh PA
when I write music I really like to
explore the intersection of maybe
pristine
pop music that's more orchestrated and
arranged and then how that can come
together with something more
experimental and spontaneous so it's
it's sort of being in control and then
losing control at the same time I'd like
to incorporate a lot of the patterns
that I hear in my mind whether it's
patterns of melody patterns of texture
I'm very inspired by the typography here
architecture mixing with nature and when
I make music I'm very attuned to those
textures and layers and repetitions and
patterns which I do see around me in
Pittsburgh you can feel kind of
claustrophobic but then you can be in
these incredible mountaintops and have
these very inspiring vistas and I think
that dichotomy and that contradiction
for me really feels my own creativity
and just inspires me to create music